hey what's up guys so today we're going
to be building out this looping abstract
wet Road animation together I originally
created this scene for the endless
engine's top 100 Montage that we did a
few weeks ago so let's rebuild this in
Cinema 4D but if you're in blender or
unreal or Maya 3DS whatever you can
follow along and Implement some of these
same tips and tricks I'm going to walk
you guys through a lot of cool stuff
like how to add realistic looking
puddles to this wet asphalt how to get
those Reflections popping with hdris and
IES lights and I'll even show you guys
how to add these cool asphalt patches as
well we're gonna add realistic camera
shake and I'm going to show you how to
set up Aces inside of octane so let's
just jump right in the first thing I
want to do is get a road and there's
lots of ways you can do that you could
go to polygon.com and grab some of their
roads here quick little bridge I know
has roads as well or you could go out
and photo scan a road say with your
phone or even with a drone you could do
long stretches that way so I believe
this is a polygon material and I'm just
gonna make a plane here I'm gonna drop
this onto the plane and we have as you
can see a road chilling here but I want
to duplicate it so with the plane
selected let's hold alt and I'm going to
pop that into a cloner and it's cloning
it along the wrong axis I want it to be
cloned along in this axis yes perfect
and let's go ahead and open this up
let's see how long let's see how big
this is 400 centimeters so we want to
duplicate it by
400 centimeters and give ourselves
enough Runway here so we can go as fast
as we want all right so we have a road
but now what do we do with it let's make
a camera you do this a number of
different ways you can hit shift C and
type in camera and make a camera like
that or in the octane live viewer you
can go to objects octane camera but I
made myself a little button right here
and I'm going to hop into the camera if
I hit shift V that's going to bring up
our safe frames and I know I want this
to be kind of a wide screen setup so I'm
going to go to my render settings here
and let's do like 1920 by 810 that's
gonna be that nice 237 aspect ratio 24
frames a second we're going to render
all of our frames here Ctrl D will bring
up your project settings your attributes
and I'll set that to 24 as well so now
we're in a true 24 frame timeline here
and I'm going to actually animate this
camera along a spline to make things
easier I'm going to go into my front
view I'm just hitting the middle Mouse
button
signed you let's go ahead and grab this
little spline pen here I'm going to do a
spline Point here a spline point there
I'm hit zero
to grab this rectangular selection tool
grab both of those right click and make
sure they're set to hard interpolation
that means there's no bezier curves
they're just two points in the wind now
I want to make sure that these are along
the same like y-axis so a shortcut to do
this if you hit t for scale and you grab
this Y and hold shift bring it all the
way down to zero it'll even those two
out perfectly another way to do it is go
down to this little bottom guy and make
sure that both of these
should be set to 100 and then you know
that's a straight line so let's move
this point here let's move this point
down here now we have a spline kind of
over this road and I want to connect the
camera to it right so what we'll do is
we will right click this camera and
we're going to go to animation tags
aligned to spline boom and we're going
to drag that spline right into the
spline path and if we hop into our
camera and we animate this position we
can start to see is getting us the look
we want so I'm going to give myself a
little bit more frames to work with
let's say 150 frames and we're going to
take this align to spline tag make a
keyframe on the position go to the very
end and set that to 100 and close that
keyframe out make sure very important
close that keyframe out all right so
back to frame one you'll notice though
it starts up and it ramps up we get to
speed and then we kind of slow down it
looks really weird we don't want that
especially if we want this thing to Loop
too what I'll do is Select this keyframe
I'm going to go to this spline type and
just set it to linear I'm going to do
that for both of these guys so now we
just snap into that full motion but you
actually notice look it's still doing it
it's still ramping up and ramping back
down and I think it has to do with our
spline and if we change the intermediate
points to say uniform
then
we'll start to be moving linearly
from point A to point B and that's
exactly what we want especially when we
want this thing to Loop so let's adjust
our camera angle a little bit as well as
the spline height so we can bring this
spline down just a little bit closer to
the road that means more motion blur is
going to be whipping by I also want to
take this camera
kind of position it here we can move the
spline over to
so that we're like actually in the road
we can as well we can select the camera
and maybe take it to like a 50 or
something
a little bit more cinematic but I like
this boom that is that is moving I love
it so obviously the first frame has
emptiness so I'm gonna grab that first
point on our spline and just move it
back and until we fill the frame there
this feels great to me let's see what it
looks like in render View and this looks
not oh we want it to look but that's
okay because the next thing we're going
to work on is lighting I'm gonna go
ahead and like dock this over here so we
can kind of see both so I want to start
with an hdri with octane you can use
this hdri environment what we can do
here is drop in any hdri that we want
into this slot hdris are essentially
full 360 images taken at different
exposures to give you a full range of
the brightest brights and the darkest
darks and it's going to light your scene
in an accurate way one of my favorite
places to get hdris is actually
polyhaven they do models they do hdris
they do materials it's all free it's all
super high res and you can search from
all these different styles of hdris but
the one I'm going to be using today is
called Manhattan nights um a guy from
New York actually took these in
Manhattan patent and I'm going to be
using a plug-in from grayscale gorilla
called hdri link and it's the quickest
way to add hdris and swap between them
in c4d it's my favorite we just need to
take this environment tag drag the
texture into this link right here boom
and if we open it up this is the plus
Library Grace go gorilla plus we can go
to user hdris we got Manhattan nights
and we can just kind of start swapping
through these to find the look we want
but we don't need to get too locked in
here but we need to work on the
reflections because I want it to look
rainy right and the best way to do that
in my opinion yes you can use noise and
you can plug the noise into the specular
Channel or the roughness Channel but
what I like doing is using an asset pack
called puddle maps by dizzyviper and he
put together these incredible wet puddle
textures for you to use in any program
you want you're going to get some really
realistic puddles here so let's take
take a look at what's actually making
this wet reflective road right now by
default everything is just wet right but
it's these puddle maps that are really
taking it to the max so I'm only using
two of them and I'm combining them with
the roughness from the actual Road
material so I think I'm using this map
here it's basically saying anything that
is black there's no roughness and
anything that's white the reflection is
spread out so much so that it looks like
it's not even reflective that's our
first one I'm using this other one to
kind of simulate uh tires so I'm
combining those two to get us this look
right here we're plugging this into the
roughness channel right each one has
their own transform that I'm using to
scale up and scale down obviously you
can see that tiling now we don't want
that and I'm going through and I'm
giving these Octane gradients and these
gradients I'm using them to really art
direct the way the light bounces off of
this road so that's really it when it
comes to the puddle Maps as soon as we
add motion blur right with the octane
camera you have the octane camera tag
there's a motion blur section and I'm
going to hit enable and definitely save
this before we do this the shutter right
since we're at 24 frames per second
technically we'll be at Double that or
half that so 1 over 48 so 24 doubles to
48 and you're going to go 1 divided by
48. boom look at that dude that looks
that looks great that looks so good
already all right we're getting much
closer to our final look the motion blur
really really adds to this so much it
looks like we're on a Tarmac or
something but we're not done we got a
lot more to do here a lot more tricks to
utilize so Asus the sponsor of today's
video is putting on their Pro artist
awards for 2023 and I am honored to be
the judge in the animation category it
is a free to enter Global challenge with
a bunch of sweet prizes so myself and
Asus challenge y'all to make a piece of
3D art that speaks to the theme of
seeing an incredible future an
incredible future could be a number of
things it could be the freedom to create
freely could be a beautiful world where
humanity and nature live as one now
there's a few categories but for the
animation category there's going to be
two winners so the runner-up is getting
a Zenbook Pro 16x OLED display laptop
for creating your goodness on the go as
well as a pro art z790 Creator Wi-Fi
motherboard but the winner y'all the
winner is gonna get a pro Art Studio
book 16 OLED laptop along with an Asus
Pro art display there's also potential
for the winning artists to have their
art as the official demo project on
asus's new spatial Vision 3D OLED
display technology that means your art
is gonna be popping up into people's
living rooms that's gonna be pretty
sweet you know and also on top of all
that good stuff the winner gets just 10
000 bucks how about how about 10K that
sounds nice submissions open today that
is April 15th and that goes all the way
through July 15th the winners will be
announced soon after I I know someone
from this community one of y'all is
gonna win this we've been doing these
challenges for so long this show Asus
what we can do so click that link down
below even if you just want to do it for
fun that's honestly more important click
that link learn a little bit more about
this challenge that Asus is holding and
see how it can inspire you guys to make
your next piece of awesome art and
speaking of art let's get back to ours
now the next thing I'm gonna do is
something that I found when I was
driving home one night the headlights of
the car behind me it was far enough back
that it reflected off of the asphalt and
it helped because it was a rainy night
and it looked exactly like what I was
creating here so I wanted to double down
on that so let me walk you guys through
how IES lights work but first off what
the heck is an IES light and IES light
is just a profile for your light shape
so there's a few packs that you can find
online for free I'll drop them down in
the description below for you guys and
let me just load one up here alright so
octane has its own IES light setup so
I'm just go ahead and click that uh
let's go in here and we're going to drag
and drop one of these IES profiles we'll
hit no and the first thing you'll notice
is it doesn't really look like it's
working but trust it is you just need to
scale down this light
we'll bring it up out of the ground in
just a little bit we can kind of see
that shape definitely but let's make it
more intense we want to uncheck surface
brightness and look at that we have a
super cool shaped light here I also want
to change the color temperature of this
light if we go to the temperature I'm
gonna just set it to 4200
right so it's more of like a Tungsten
and if we hop into the camera and we
actually need to find where the heck our
camera is in comparison with this light
all right our camera's way down there
let's just go to the middle of the of
the render here let's see yep there it
is let's go to update checklist uncheck
camera that way when I hop out of the
camera
the viewport will still be live and we
just want to find that nice balance we
can back it up raise it up lower it
that's not bad right there actually
I like that so I'm gonna duplicate it
because obviously we want two headlights
right so holding control
we got two headlights back there it's
looking really nice if we go into our
octane camera tag we can actually go to
the camera imager we can check that on
and we have some extra options in here
which are really nice we can actually do
some hot pixel removal and bring this
down but at a certain point it starts to
get
a little crunchy right so we need to
find the right balance we need the right
amount of samples
so we can throw maybe 500 samples at it
and let it render just a little bit
longer and it'll clean that up just a
bit we can also enable spectral denoiser
once it gets to 500 it will denoise it
right so this is intense we can blend it
here right so we just work in a little
bit of that D noise I'm a sucker for
vignette too
um so I'm going to crank that up just a
bit and it really starts to bring the
focus of the scene on that Center
highlighted bit I like those lights now
obviously you saw I scrubbed but the
lights didn't come with and I'm going to
take both of them and make them a child
of the camera so wherever the camera
goes those lights are also going so the
next thing I want to show you guys is
how to get these like asphalt crack fill
in looking things I don't know exactly
what they're called but this look is so
cool to me it's such a cool way to break
up the render and I just just want to
have these things whipping by giving you
these crazy looks and just kind of
Mesmerize you so let's let's build this
out so let's make a new scene
let's get rid of this all right here's
what I'm going to do let's make a plane
I'll scale it way up uh let's get a
figure as well so we know what we're
dealing with let's grab another plane
let's go n b right so I want to open
this up open this up and to me what that
image looked like was a bunch of noodles
dropped on the floor and that's exactly
what I'm gonna do so I'm gonna give this
enough to work with here something like
this perhaps I'm gonna make this
editable light by hitting C
and let's go to the line mode I'm just
gonna randomly select with this
selection tool a bunch of these lines
just like this so we're going to right
click this and convert these edges to a
spline now if we pull that spline up we
hide our plane right we have this shape
here this is awesome let's go ahead and
give it some thickness so I'm gonna make
a circle spline we'll scale that down
I'll grab both of these the circle
spline and the spline grid I'm going to
hold Ctrl alt and I'm going to drop it
into a sweep and look at that we got
some stuff I'm gonna bring this sweep up
into the air and if I take that spline
let's go to point mode grab all those
points I'm going to chamfer all of these
edges here
just so they're all rounded out and if
we right click the spline and go to our
simulation tags and give it a rope tag
and we hit play
then that's going to fall through the
floor because we need to give our plane
a collider tag boom and that is
wonderful that is wonderful but how do
we get them to like worm out right all
you need to do I'm going to hit shift C
I'm gonna find turbulence and let's just
bring that in here by default is just
okay so I want to
bring this up by a hundred just make it
crazy the scale's too large so we need
to scale it to like
I don't know 50 so it's all wacky yes
all right so now we have to mess with
our rope tag so bendiness let's try five
okay still a little uh oh let's go to
the spline and set the intermediate
points to uniform there we go
yes yes that is exactly exactly what we
want I just want to get a black and
white view of this so I believe the
simplest way to do that would be to drop
a white luminescent material on the
sweep and a black material without
reflection
onto the plane okay so when we render
this in the viewport this is perfect
right let's go like 4 000 by uh 1500 but
you see all this weird stepping right
here we don't want that at all so what
we need to do is actually under our
settings here under our viewport
renderer it should be
anti-aliasing anti-aliasing yes
f x a a and we want geometry only for
the filter let's render it again and see
if it gets rid of this default camera
and our yes here we go boom that's
perfect so I'll save this out as a PNG
and let's go back into our scene here
we're going to hop out of the camera I'm
gonna make a plane
4 000 by 1500 we'll rotate it and we're
gonna have this live just above our road
I'm gonna move it up like 0.1
centimeters
make a new material in my case an octane
material we're going to drop it onto
this plane and if we drop it into the
opacity and oh my goodness that looks
like some Ramen
what on Earth is happening
there's a glitch in The Matrix y'all it
works it totally works let's scale it
we can even stretch it out if we want we
can duplicate it
flip it around we can even simulate a
couple other ones if we want but for
this I think totally works let's go
ahead and adjust the material itself
though because it's not right first
thing we'll do is actually change the
diffuse color
I'll just grab like the color of this
road and then all we need to do is just
kind of up the roughness of this thing
and we start to get that look that we're
going for and with motion blur let's
turn that back on
we really want them to stand out we can
take the index of reflection up to say
like five
and they'll start to really pop out of
this thing I can set it to one and
they're going to be just chromed out it
really is a subtle touch that comes
together when you're just whipping
through this road it adds to that like
Speed Line kind of effect that we're
getting here in a very realistic kind of
way so the last thing I want to talk
about is camera shake and there again is
a number of ways that you can do this
you can film some camera Shake yourself
with your camera track that footage and
apply it to your shot after it's
rendered but I love doing it in the
program because that way the light
reacts 100 realistically with the shake
that you're putting into it I know Ian
Hubert has a really cool camera Shake
plug-in for blender if you guys are on
that side but the way I'm gonna do it is
actually with another grayscale gorilla
plug-in called gorilla Cam and what it
does is it references your original
camera it makes an instance of it
essentially and adds this gorilla cam
tag to it and all of your camera Shake
settings are going to be controlled via
this tag right here so what I like doing
just right off the bat going to zeros
okay because I can build up from from no
shake if we hit play and we keep it very
subtle guys very very subtle if I take
rotation fasting to like 100 medium
let's just play with this let's see what
we can do we can have like two degrees
of some slow rotation but really that is
about it you know we can smooth out that
camera Shake by 50 all kind of different
looks you guys can get out of this so
one other thing I want to do to add a
bit more chaos to this very simple scene
is to actually just orbit my hdri a
little bit and now would be the time to
actually go through your hdris and find
one that you feel works best for your
scene on the first frame I'm gonna make
a keyframe on the rotation X and we can
see that this is going to give us a
bunch of different looks here as we
rotate this horizontally and we're going
to go to the very end and let's set this
to one which will be a full 3 60 close
out that keyframe I'm also going to make
sure these keyframes are set to linear
that way they just start moving from
frame one that's going to add a nice bit
of variety to our road and to this
little intro graphic like that that's so
cool now before I render this out I want
to show you guys how to set up aces in
C40 it's a lot easier than you think but
it really is going to be perfect for
this for those of you who don't know
Aces is a certain color profile and it's
going to treat our light information in
a very specific way that allows us to
get the most out of our highlights the
most data out of our shadows and it's
just going to make for the cleanest
image possible when we export this thing
you're going to download the link in the
description it's this open color IO
folder this Aces 1.2 folder there might
be a more updated one at this point but
what I'm looking at is this
config.icio file that is the file right
there and what we're going to do is go
up to Octane octane settings we're going
to go to settings and color management
and we're going to navigate to that
config file right here once you have
that locked in all we're really going to
do is go to the camera imager we're
going to go to Ocio
and we're going to make sure that we go
to Aces Rec 709 Asus Rec 709 basically
from there you're going to be able to
select the Asus Rec 709 color profile
and it's going to load it up like this
and you know it works when you select
the octane camera tag you go to camera
imager right we checked it on earlier
and you shouldn't be able to adjust the
gamma if I move this gamma up and down
nothing should happen and that's how we
know it works but what we can do is we
can take this exposure and we can say
let's go to like three or something the
way it rolls off with the highlights is
just absolutely beautiful when you go to
render this out it's not going to look
like this so if you go to the export
settings here if we do an octane render
is exactly what we want we go to our
octane render settings we can change
this buffer type to 8-bit and take the
color space to Ocio and we can select
our color space output and we'll do Rec
709 that way it just kind of looks like
what we're seeing here you can do all
your stuff individually later you can of
course export in normal Aces and then
change your DaVinci project settings to
work in Aces and do it that way but I
just like to keep things simple and do
it like this I'm really really happy
with these results so let's give it a
render and see what it's looking like
all right so this is what we just made
at first glance this is just too fast
for me and you can actually see all the
repetitive textures on the puddles and
whatnot so what I did is render out a
slower version where you can actually
tell what the camera Shake is doing you
can actually see the reflections on the
puddles on the road a little bit more
you can see the detail that we added a
bit more this is a lot better for me now
the orbiting hdri is a little intense it
is going a little fast for me so for my
final version I switched out the hdri I
left it as is and I'm very happy with
these results right here and take a look
at the difference between the raw render
and the processing in DaVinci it's a
very very simple setup I'm using film
Grain on top I have a little lens effect
that I'm bringing in very subtly and as
far as color correction goes it's a very
simple setup this first node right here
is just a color boost the second one is
a pretty harsh vignette using this
little circular window here and dropping
the gamma and the third one is just a
very subtle glow and that's it the
difference between the raw render and
the processed Da Vinci render is huge
for me and it's such a simple thing to
do don't miss it it's important hey
thanks for hanging out with me guys I
really appreciate it if you learned a
thing or two leave a comment down below
let's get a little chat going subscribe
if you're not subscribed already
definitely look into the Asus Pro artist
Awards it's a super cool way to stretch
yourself as an artist over these next
few months here before we get into our
August Community challenge because we're
gonna do another one y'all so thank you
guys again have a good one I'll catch
y'all soon peace
thank you